all right what is going on there reject
am i i'm i'm in focus okay it goes make
sure the camera's in focus what's going
on there reject nation
greg here today
so uh
yeah
yeah this is gonna be a bit of a weird
video i i don't i'm not the kind of guy
to just like be like hey i'm gonna talk
about another youtuber right now and
it's not it's not like a call out video
or something like that in fact it's it's
quite the opposite i wanted to talk
about chris stuckman in case you guys
know what chris stuckman is he's an all
right youtuber he's kind of struggling
right now
now hicka stuckman is one of the biggest
and probably the biggest movie critic
solo movie critic on youtube he's one of
the few youtubers that whenever he
uploads a video i at very least make a
note that i'm going to watch that video
today or a minimum tomorrow i i will
watch it i i am stuck monized to say the
least and i want to talk about what he's
been doing as of late with what he's
been pursuing in filmmaking then the
question was posed to me like why do you
want to do this video like this is
something i've been thinking about for a
couple weeks like why do you want to do
this you know like why do you really
give a [ __ ] about what chris stuckman's
doing you know why do you what do you
care about this then i thought about it
and i realized why what his journey is
is something that's very personal for me
so in this video i'm going to share
something that i have not talked
publicly about i feel like it's
important for me to express this
personal story because
that would explain why i'm even here
trying to show support for chris
stuckman right now in case you guys
don't know most of you probably already
watched chris stuckman but in case you
don't know um about eight months ago
there was this big announcement and
deadline about how chris stuckman is
writing and directing his own feature
film and it was a big day it was a big
day and it was really exciting being
especially for someone like me who
already looks up to chris suckman to be
able to do a feature film a little bit
jealous but mainly proud of the guy and
then a couple months ago he did a video
where he was expressing that there was a
lot of delays that happened with this
movie one of the catalyst moments of it
had to do around the time of the whole
ayatse strike situation and then
eventually led to him realizing that you
know they'd be able to probably cut
corners with their filmmaking that he
could probably make an okay movie it
more than likely would not be able to
become the movie that he sought to make
that he envisions because of the funding
they currently had at the time so what
he ended up doing was launching this
kickstarter for his movie
and
oh boy uh in like 24 hours it
made over 250 000 from my understanding
it's b it's on track to become the
highest grossing horror movie on
kickstarter and believe me there's a lot
of them and it's currently the highest
trending campaign in the horror movie
category which is a big deal because
there's a there's a lot of those so full
disclosure couple things i have pledged
to as kickstarter secondly i want to
make this really clear no one reached
out to me like hey greg saw your channel
any chance you want to like promote this
that's not what happened at all in fact
i am the one who reached out to chris
duckman myself you know real quick
i'm sure i could find a clip of chris
stuckman describing what this movie is
so let me roll like some footage of
chris explain what this movie is shelby
oaks is a horror film about missing
paranormal investigators who were very
active in the youtube sphere around the
mid 2000s when the platform first
launched the film explores the dark
legacy that that group uncovered and how
it has ever reaching effects even 12
years into the future as the lead
paranormal investigator riley is
desperately searched for by her older
sister mia and as mia begins to uncover
disturbing leads related to the
disappearance of the paranormal
paranoids she discovers evidence of a
hidden supernatural evil dating all the
way back to her and riley's childhood i
really support this project i really
believe in him as a filmmaker i mean you
watch his movie reviews this guy clearly
knows what he's talking about and i
think it's just a fun journey to see if
this guy can put his money where his
mouth is so if you're able to support
the shelby oaks kickstarter please
there's a link in the description box
and pin comment i'm going to make sure
to do that unless of course you're
thinking about pledging to our patreon
and then then pledge for our patreon
share support for shelby oaks now really
the the only extra touch i can give to
this is why what he's doing means so
much to me in my personal life some of
you guys might know this that my main
passion is actually in screenwriting
that's right the jackass is always
talking about marvel dc and star wars
actually has a big passion for
psychological supernatural horror-driven
movies like chris duckman's movie like
that genre i'm like that's that's mainly
what i write in cool yeah it's like it
goes without saying that for someone who
talks about movies for a living and then
is able to go on to making his own that
alone is inspiring but there's a little
bit more to the story than that so in
the past few years there's been a couple
of projects one project that was public
about on this channel which i do got to
acknowledge
and uh yeah some embarrassment that just
like rose up out of me uh out of that
just remembering and then there's
another project that i've been waiting
for like my baller chris stuckman move
like for for this movie to get announced
and then when you're reading through the
paragraphs you're like what is that
gregor's name like i wanted that
situation to happen but uh yeah that's i
i have to talk about this so the first
thing there's a movie that was in
development that we were working on that
i co-wrote and uh we had a lot of like
pretty big people attached to it it just
really seemed like it was gonna be made
and then the team behind it was like
yeah you should make an announcement on
your channel and even at the time i was
like yeah
are we jumping the shark a little bit
here you know shouldn't we wait till
we're like actually really filming we
went ahead and did it and uh yeah and
then and it looked like it was about to
happen but but then didn't the
scheduling conflicts occur because
everyone's working all the time on their
other movies and stuff like they are i'm
not even there working on their movies
and stuff and admittedly it was pretty
like it was embarrassing to like make a
big announcement feel like guys i got
something special to share with you and
now it's not happening but it's not dead
i can't say it's dead because it's
really just one of those things that's
on pause right now and this other
project
was something that i did before that see
like uh i don't really want to give any
names here a couple years ago there's a
gentleman i met who is a quite revered
in the industry in the profession that
he has like he's really well regarded i
got to meeting him one night and uh
at a friend's birthday party i believe
and we just talked about movies all day
we really just you know we we click man
you feel the sparks man he's a great guy
he's like a great guy then a couple days
later he he hit me up and he's like hey
i actually have this movie idea if i've
had it for a while and i got all these
this concept art to develop word like do
you want to write it and i was like yeah
let me let me have a shot at writing
this because that's always been my dream
is to write through the year and a half
frost it was like a long process of
writing and rewriting eventually
got it to a studio i won't say which one
it's not one of the major ones like
warner brothers or something but it's a
studio that more than likely you have
heard i've got to the studio studio now
owns it i signed the contracts on the
deal a deal done on my end i'm square
i'm good to go
and that was about
four
years ago i want to say it was a while
ago hey i was proud of that because not
one bit of that process even from
meeting that gentleman he had never seen
the real rejects so i i was actually
proud of the fact that
i didn't have to use any of like hey we
got a following on youtube in order to
get it fine like i don't think there's
anything wrong with that personally i
think that's like use whatever tools you
have at your disposal i 100 believe in
that i was just kind of
like giddy about like i didn't have to
do that and the script got to where it
was and i'm such a i'm so such an
amateur at this i'm so like intermediate
at this and this is a big part of why i
think chris stuckman's kickstarter is so
rewarding i don't understand so much
with the ins and outs of the business
side of things you know like they
literally can do whatever they want with
it and my name will just be attached
like that happens all the time and
honestly like 99 of the time a lot of
people don't realize this no vast
majority of screenplays just sit on
shelves they don't actually get made
that's within like these studios whether
they'd be smaller big ones most don't
get made but like every few months i
will get some like random update which
i'm which i'm grateful for and and
they're usually like really cool updates
they're it's their updates that get me
excited they're updates that make me
feel like oh my god this is actually
going to get made because at the end of
the day that this that feeling that
chris stuckman expressed in his video
knowing the optics surrounding him of
youtuber turned filmmaker now going to
make his own movie there's going to just
be a whole like much more critical eyes
on him to see like hey he's been
criticizing [ __ ] for a while can you
actually get this done and for me i'm
like ah no one's really gonna
take me seriously unless there's
something actually made and if it's made
it has to be good for somebody like
somebody has to actually get made
and for the past like a few years i get
some random update every few months
about like hey it looks like it's
actually getting a shot we're going to
start gearing up in december we're going
to start gearing up february there's
always something like we're going to
start gearing up to do this we're going
to start gearing up to do this we're
going to start gearing up to do this and
it's in the hands of so many other
people and other people you got to
answer to and and i like there's just so
much i don't personally quite get about
it especially when working with these
studios like there's so much i don't
understand and then my favorite updates
honestly if there's one that i always
find really positive the lead character
in that project which i really do
believe in by the way i think it's i
like the script a lot and i think it
would be a really cool movie but the
whole thing is just out of my hands the
main character is a lady and and there's
so many actresses actresses i just love
who
will read it and then they'll want to do
it they'll want to do it but then all
the kind of things chris stuckman talked
about and for funding issues shooting
schedule conflicts because like everyone
is already involved they're working on
other things and then like we have one
actress who i was like oh man that would
be nuts if we got her and she wanted to
do it but
there was a certain time frame that she
wanted to film at where the director he
couldn't make that work because he was
working on something else at the time a
whole bunch of different variations of
the story have happened so many times
you know and also it was like pretty
demotivating for a while you know
because at the end of the day i think
most of us don't want to just
write like a lot of us a lot of people
who write love to love to write but at
the end of the day it's like you want
one of these to get actually made right
what he's done while he's working with
producers obviously you have to there's
no way he is taking this into his own
hands as much as possible it's not
dealing with a lot of the things
with a lot of the feedback i'd say i'm
being kind of careful of my words here a
lot of the feedback that i've heard of
like maybe we gotta change this changes
cut this work around this and it's like
man that's really
it's really harming the story like a lot
of things i hear i'm like that's really
harming this and the stuff i'm writing
is not like crazy budget [ __ ] you know
it's around the ballpark of what chris
stuckman's actually aiming for so i get
it like i i i i really sympathize with
him in this situation the fact that he's
doing it this way taking this leap
something that was posed to us for the
project that i announced here when that
got put to a halt they were like do you
want to do a i was like
nah i don't i don't really want to do a
kickstarter i just i had a lack of
confidence at the time
so i'm here to announce we are launching
our kickstarter now i'm not gonna do
that the fact that he likes to push past
that fear decided to launch it and now
it's seeing so much success it's like
almost at a half a million dollars this
kickstarter already it's going till the
end of the month i want to say why i
believe even more in this project now
than before is because he already was
aware of the pressure
of having to basically prove himself
right he was already aware of that now
when you're receiving you know financial
support from your own audience like
these are the people you you wanted to
then to pay to see your movie never seen
a financial support to get it made he's
gonna make it better
than
ever like let me put it to you like this
if he had just only gotten like the the
money he needed to really fulfill the
vision he had from a studio directly
instead of having to start a kickstarter
let's say he just got that money i think
he'd make a good movie i don't feel like
it'd be as good as the one he's gonna
make now because when you have your
audience supporting you like that
there's something in you that has to
click and then from the brief times i've
talked with this man who's a very very
kind person very kind very sincere as
about as sincere as you'd expect him to
be especially watch his videos you know
that he's gonna take this more serious
than ever and he's gonna try to make
this even better than before because of
the fact that he knows his audience is
throwing down money to help support his
movie and his kickstarter he's aiming to
show you the ins and outs the
nitty-gritty of the development process
just trying to get one of these goddamn
things made and i love that he's willing
to share that because there's so much of
it that i could have used and the fact
that he's doing this as independently as
possible with the team that he obviously
trusts with the support of you guys he's
making this like a collective community
experience i think it's a great path for
a lot of us to go down because 99 of the
i live in los angeles all right so throw
a rock out the window you're you're
bound to hit a screenwriter an actor you
know like you're gonna find someone in
this building alone i know there's like
other people here who are also in the
field hey guys i wish i thought of this
like when i was filming it but i'm like
i'm trimming this down right now and i'm
realizing that he's getting this all
done while staying in his own hometown
which is also incredibly inspiring i
can't tell you the amount of people i've
met that have moved out here to try to
make it happen and then they get
discouraged and move back home and just
don't follow their dreams anymore
because they feel like they didn't make
it out in la and he's proving
that you can do this
while
being in your own hometown building a
community out there that is
that is seriously like mesmerizing to me
i'm getting nipple chills just talking
about it right now
what he's doing in the indie filmmaking
route i think is very inspiring and is
conquering obstacles
that a lot of us can
learn from
and so
yeah i just want to throw my support for
him publicly and i wanted to encourage
you guys to support the project as well
and
yeah and uh if any of my things ever get
shot
we'll let you know you know but thank
you guys for being here i really
appreciate you like kicking it with me
for now i'll talk to you guys soon
[Music]
you